here in germany demonstrations against
coronavirus restrictions are becoming
more frequent and more violent with many
ending in clashes with police
authorities say right-wing extremists
are exploiting the situation to push
their own agenda
some politicians are facing a campaign
of intimidation protesters with flaming
tortures recently showed up outside the
home of the health minister in the
eastern state of saxony and earlier this
week police seized weapons in a series
of raids after death threats were made
against saxony's state premier the
government has warned of growing
radicalization but some who've spent
their lives fighting extremism say the
threat has always been there it's just
becoming more visible
knows exactly where to find the people
she has been fighting for decades
here resides the neo-nazi political
party the third path its members incite
hatred against foreigners and anyone who
thinks differently germany's domestic
intelligence service monitors the party
which it has classified as extremist and
anti-constitutional
once again if i come i would love it if
they would just go away i want them out
of our town right wing radicalism is not
welcome here it simply has nothing at
all to do with democracy
but the small radical neo-nazi party is
established in carter's hometown of plun
in the former east germany third path
members were elected to the town council
where they are able to shape political
life
carter is the cherrywoman of an
association that is committed to
fighting the dangers of the extreme
right because of this she often receives
threats
and know that someone who is very close
to the third path lives in the flat
under you and you are attacked in the
stairwell with i'm going to kill you and
i'm going to shoot you with
the situation has worsened due to the
covet pandemic some people are
dissatisfied with the government's
pandemic mitigation measures saying they
are too strict the radical right takes
advantage of this dissatisfaction
several extremist groups are
increasingly agitating people and
calling for demonstrations protests like
these are happening in many places in
germany but in the eastern state of
saxony they're especially aggressive
police arrested one man after a raid he
and others reportedly discussed online
killing saxony state minister
others marched with torches in front of
the house of the state's minister of
health pictures of that even went viral
on twitter
such demonstrators are a minority here
but they are loud and aggressive
their tone has become more radicalized
and they aren't hiding it anymore they
openly threaten to kill politicians that
kind of thing never happened before not
like this
visits various parts of the city and
educates people about the danger posed
by the radical right
quitting is not an option she doesn't
want to let her hometown fall prey to
extremist forces
i'm just the kind of person who speaks
up and lets people know what she thinks
i was always very vocal this isn't new i
just have to speak out for what i
believe in
einstein and that's what she'll keep
doing standing up against dangerous
extremism
let's bring in dw political
correspondent hans brunt now hans
how sure are police that these protests
are being infiltrated by right-wing
groups could it be that these groups are
simply becoming more hostile
there's no doubt about the presence of
right-wing groups they quite openly
participate in demonstrations against
the covet restrictions
under their flags wearing uniforms and
so on there's also a very visible
overlap between online groups run by
right wing
extremists and those groups that
mobilize people to attend such
demonstrations
so it's very clear that
there is
a strong influence of right wingers
this influence extends also to the
right-wing populist party the
alternative for germany which is
represented in many parliaments in
germany and which also has parts of it
which are regarded by the authorities as
right-wing extremists at the same time
you have to say that the dissatisfaction
amongst people who are
impacted by the uh anti-corona
restrictions people especially who are
not vaccinated that that anger is
growing and certainly that anger is
being uh in a sense um
stirred by by the right-wing extremist
groups um so there is
a kind of um
synergy i think one could call it
between the dissatisfaction on the
street and the intentions of the
right-wing extremists well during his
first address to parliament german
chancellor olaf schultz was at pains to
stress that germany wasn't divided on
vaccinations but he did address the
growing protests and violence let's hear
what he had to say
above us
what we observe in germany today is a
denial of reality absurd conspiracy
theories
deliberate disinformation and violent
extremism
clearly
a small extremist minority in our
country has turned its back not only on
science rational thinking and reason
but also on our society our democracy
our community and our state
well you heard it there a small minority
of extremists but clearly troubling
nonetheless and something that the
german administration wants to tackle
how will they go about that
yes this new german government has
declared right-wing extremism as the
major threat against security
in germany in other words much more
threatening than for instance islamist
terrorism or left-wing extremism
and the government has announced that it
will step up its actions against
right-wing extremists at the moment the
government is too new in a sense for one
to see exactly what steps they are
likely to implement
at the same time you have to say it's
not just a
strategy of repression that the
government wants to follow it also wants
to open up a dialogue towards people who
are dissatisfied with government policy
there is a large number of people who
distrust
authority with distrust government
especially in the former east germany
and these people wants to bring back on
side as it were bring them back into the
democratic fold one could say
because amongst them the
extremism is not necessarily part of
their
conviction it's just something that they
are being pulled towards because of
their general dissatisfaction
yes a troubling development indeed hans
brunt dw's political correspondent
thanks very much for the analysis
now for a breakdown of some pandemic
developments elsewhere in the world
health ministers from the g7 are calling
the omicron variant the biggest current
threat to global public health they say
its emergence means it's more important
than ever for countries to work closely
together and share data the us center
for disease control is recommending
people receive mrna covert 19 vaccines
instead of johnson johnson's single shot
vaccine due to a rare blood clotting
disorder and germany's robert koch
institute says the omicron variant will
likely become the dominant variant here
very soon